ah September which means school is back
in session which also means adorable
back-to-school photos from all of our
favorite syllabic kiddos we put them in
fancy outfits Neil Patrick Harris shared
this adorable shot his twins look too
cool for kindergarten Kelly Ripa
captured Joaquin and Lola's first days
of 8th and 10th grade respectively
big bro Michael already headed off to
college like my dreams for my kids I
want my son to be a a sports hero and
and then you fight you know figure out
that the apple doesn't fall that far
from the tree Vanessa Lachey Instagram
did this to cute pic of her Knicks baby
boy Camden and Elton John captured this
sweet moment with his own boys bethany
frankel showed off daughter brings a new
backpack she's really fun and loving
we're just like best friends
while Kim Zolciak snapchatted KJ in
Cash's back-to-school fashions what a
blessing and Jenna Dewan Tatum posted
her own first day of school look yeah
those early morning drop-offs and be
rough